نتوقف في هذه الفقره عند انظمه الصواريخ
هاي مارس الملكيه وذلك بعد ان كشف مسؤولون
بالفانتاغون عن تشويش روسي اثر على فاعليه
المنظومه الصاروخيه نبدا من يونيو حزيران
عام 2022 حيث زودت الولايات المتحده
القوات الاوكرانيه براجمات صواريخ من نوع
هاي مارس وصواريخ اخرى موجهه بالاقمار
الصناعيه استخدمت تلك الصواريخ لضرب
مستودعات الذخيره الروسيه والامدادات
اللوجستيه ومراكز قياده القوات الروسيه
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تصنف منظومه هيمرس على انها راجمه
الصواريخ دقيقه التوجيه تحمل الواحده منها
سته صواريخ من عيار 2007
بمدى يقدر بنحو 80 كم لكن الولايات
المتحده لم تزود اوكرانيا بنظام هاي مارس
للصواريخ الباليستيه الذي يبلغ مداها 300
كم لانها قادره على ضرب مواقع داخل روسيا
وهذا ما لا تريده
وقد كانت صحيفه قد نقلت عن مسؤولين
امريكيين القول ان البنتاجوان اجرى
تعديلات سريه على منظومه هاي مارس بحيث لا
يمكنها اطلاق صواريخ بعيده المدى بما في
ذلك منظومه الصواريخ التكتيكيه
التي زود بها اوكرانيا والتي يبلغ مداها
نحو 200 لكن ماذا عن اهميه صواريخ هاي
مارس هذه في جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا هل
حققت تغيرا حاسما على الارض وماذا عن
تفاصيل هذا التشويش الروسي نبدا من
التشويش نبدا من التشويش فقد نقلت شبكه
عن مسكونا بوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه القول
ان انظمه صواريخ هايمان اصبحت اقل فاعليه
بشكل متزايد باوكرانيا بالاشهر الاخيره
وذلك بسبب التشويش الروسي المكثف
اضاف مسؤوله بانتاجون ان التشويش الروسي
اجبر المسؤولين الامريكيين والاوكرانيين
على ايجاد طرق لتعديل برنامج هاي مارس
بمواجهه جهود التشويش الروسيه المتطوره
ولكن ماذا عن التاثير الميداني احدى ابرز
الهجمات التي استخدمت فيها هذه الصواريخ
تعود الى مطلع العام الحالي في دنيا حيث
قتل فيها اكثر من 60 جنديا روسيا والى
جانب دقه التوجيه يشير خبراء عسكريون الى
ان منظومه هاي مارس تتميز بدائره استهداف
واسعا نسبيا تعطي القوات الاوكرانيه اذا
طول خصوصا عند خطوط التماس لكن الخبراء مع
ذلك يشيرون ايضا الى صعوبات تحول دون
ارسال عدد كاف من هي مارس الى اوكرانيا من
بينها توفر قطع الغيار والحاجه لتدريب عدد
كبير من الاوكرانيين لتشغيلها